bill skarsgård gives a terrifying new
take on the shape-shifting Pennywise in
the latest adaptation of Stephen King's
best-selling novel it's about a group of
young misfits terrorized by an evil
presence in their town
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm going to take you behind
the scenes of the new big-screen version
of it and reveal some freaky facts and
intriguing secrets about the making of
the movie
I'm also kicking off a new Funko pop
giveaway on this video all you have to
do is be a subscriber to my channel and
comment on the movie below for a chance
to win believe it or not babies were the
inspiration behind the movies menacing
clown yes right from the start director
Andy machete knew he wanted his version
of Pennywise to have a baby-faced
appearance with big eyes and Apple
cheeks that he felt the contrast of the
characters childlike features and his
terrifying behavior would make him all
the more disturbing giving scars got his
full-on Pennywise face took around 5
hours in initial makeup tests but they
managed to get that down to around two
and a half hours during filming that
included applying razor-sharp teeth
prosthetic pieces for his cheeks and an
enlarged skull which the special effects
makeup artists who crafted it described
as a gigantic cracked melon speaking of
teeth the prosthetics skarsgård wore led
to a buildup of drool so they decided to
embrace that as a feature of his
character and threw in some extra
special effects slime - for good measure
to really push the idea of Pennywise 'as
childlike creepiness even further the
film uses a traditional English nursery
rhyme called oranges and lemons as his
musical theme the song dates back to at
least the 18th century and despite its
playful singsong surface its lyrics have
dark connotations and may be linked to
public executions or even child
sacrifice making it the perfect theme
for penny wise when it came to creating
penny rises peepers scars God's blue
eyes were turned yellow in
post-production but director Andy
machete didn't have to resort to visual
effects to produce the war live look he
wanted for the dancing clown because
bill skarsgård has a bit for lazy left
eye which means that the swedish actor
was actually able to make penny rises
eyes point in different directions all
by himself as skarsgård told dazed
magazine all he had
simply relax the muscle in his left eye
to make that I go out and become war
lied as for penny wisest clown suit the
director wanted to avoid what he thought
as the cheap look of 20th century clown
costumes instead his instinctive choice
was for a costume that reflected more of
a bygone era so to highlight the fact
that penny wise has been terrorizing the
inhabitants of Derry Maine for an
incredibly long time his suit combines
features from the Middle Ages and the
Renaissance as well as the Elizabethan
and Victorian periods and that childlike
freakiness of the characters highlighted
once again by what the movies costume
designer has called the doll like
quality of his costume while the washed
out coloring of his clothes makes him
almost like a shadow while bill
skarsgård hopes that his take on
Pennywise will scare a whole generation
just as Tim Curry did in the 1990 TV
mini-series
the Swedish actor has already
experienced the clown stalking his own
sleep at home in Stockholm after filming
at Finnish skarsgård had recurring
visions of Pennywise in his dreams for
two weeks speaking to Empire Magazine
skarsgård said that in the dreams I was
Pennywise but I was in the wrong setting
somehow I was upset that people could
see my face and it was surreal
the first time the movies young stars
actually saw skarsgård as penny wise was
about a month into the shoot during a
scene they filmed together where he
creeps out of the fridge the filmmakers
decided to keep Pennywise hidden away
from the young actors until the last
possible moment as they wanted to create
a real feeling of tension so their
initial reactions were as fresh and
authentic as possible for some of the
actors who play the preteen members of
the losers Club bringing to life their
characters required some extra training
not in acting but in how to ride a bike
according to one of the movies producers
some of the young leads weren't so hot
when it came to pedal power so to make
sure they looked like Naturals when it
came to cycling on screen they were
given lessons in fact that was just one
part of the three weeks the young car
spent together getting to know each
other before filming began the idea was
for them to establish the kind of bond
they needed to portray on camera so they
spent lots of time outdoors swimming
riding bikes and playing practical jokes
on each other as well as having movie
nights and karaoke sessions on top of
that because the film is set in the 9th
ATS one of the producers also made the
young act as an intro to the 80s booklet
with facts about movies music and video
games as well as how people talked and
the clothes they wore though I'm
guessing that Finn wolfhard already knew
his 80s stuff thanks to his starring
role is stranger things
fans of Stephen King's novel will likely
be pleased to see the dilapidated house
at 29 he bolts Street to make an
appearance in the new movie to create
the infamous locales the filmmakers used
two different settings first they built
the exterior of the house from scratch
on a vacant lot in Oshawa Canada and to
get the right aged and run-down
appearance the design team burned and
pressure-washed new timber then painted
it silver gray as for that nolden
twisted tree see in front of the house
that actually started out life in a
neighbor's garden on their way to work
one day a member of the movie's crew
spotted the tree and thought it looked
perfect for filming so they negotiated
with the trees owner and nabbed it for
the shoot as for the interior of the
house that was shot in an existing home
whose owner gave the crew carte blanche
to make changes to creep the place up
for filming those changes included
exposing the homes original Victorian
details coating the walls with crumbling
plaster poking vines and dead leaves
through broken windows covering other
windows with specially made Victorian
era newspapers and generally filling the
place with dirt now if you've seen the
movie what did you think of it and what
were your best and worst moments from
the film let me know in the comments
below and also don't forget to subscribe
for your chance to win an awesome penny
wise Funko pop and announce the winner
on an upcoming video so turn on your
notifications to make sure you don't
miss it
the winner of my Game of Thrones
giveaway is on screen now if that's you
send me a message with your details so I
can get the prize to you if you enjoyed
this hit that thumbs up button and check
out more of my videos by tapping the
screen right here thanks for watching
and see you next time you became movie
lovers